Russia has already started a new
offensive in Ukraine.
Ukrainian officials are already
seeing a high tempo of Russian
attacks, what they fear is a
prelude to a massive new
assault.
>> One Ukrainian official says
there was record shelling in the
east this weekend, but these
drone videos also show heavy
losses for Ukrainian tanks.
CNN's David Mckenzie is in
Ukraine.
David, does Ukraine believe a
new Russian offensive has begun,
it's under way now?
>> Reporter: Victor, you can't
really set your watch to it.
What you have seen is this very
significant uptick of attacks in
certain parts of the eastern
front.
According to the nato
secretary-general at least, he
believes this has already
started.
>> We've seen it start already.
We see what Russia will do now
is send in thousands and
thousands of more troops,
accepting a very high rate of
casualty, taking big losses, but
putting pressure on the
Ukrainians.
>> Reporter: The pressure is
being felt mostly around that
eastern front, around vuhledar
where you see Russian troops in
wave after wave and getting
obliterated by Ukrainian forces,
at least based on the evidence
we've reviewed.
They've been hitting minefields,
attacked by drones and
artillery.
Even the Russian supporters are
criticizing the Russians for
throwing a huge amount of
resources without much gain.
One of the biggest issues with
the Ukraine space is they're
running short of basic large
caliber ammunition.
That's something nato will be
discussing into tomorrow to try
and ratchet up production to get
them to the front.
>> The delivery time to deliver
that ammunition is actually
increasing we heard from
Stoltenberg to 28 months from 12
months.
Quickly, David, there are
conflicting reports as to
whether Russia is gaining
traction.
From what ou're seeing, is this
a formidable, reconstitutioned
Russian force?
>> Bianna, it's certainly too
area to tell.
In the areas of bakhmut, it's
strategically important.
If you look at this sent out by
the Wagner mercenary group, it
shows Wagner in place in what
are significant parts of that
satellite village, of that area.
The Russians say they've largely
taken control of this zone.
The Ukrainians dispute that.
Our teams on the ground are
seeing that the entrances and
exits of these towns are under
Russia fire, which means for all
intents and purposes, they do
not have full control anymore of
that zone.
I remember being here several
months ago and speaking about
the same towns and villages that
were under constant bombardment
then.
So whether this attritional
warfare brings any closer the
aims of the Kremlin to take over
those areas in the east, it
certainly doesn't seem like it.
This is very, very intense
fighting, and neither side can
potentially hold out forever
with this kind of warfare.
>> David Mckenzie, thank you.
>>> Retired U.S. Army major Mike
Lyons joins us now.
Let's pick up with the claim
from this Wagner group claiming
control of back mud.
It's not just the ability to
take over the village, but the
ability to hold it.
Do you think the Russian forces
are better equipped this time
around to hold this territory
throughout the rest of the
winter into the spring offensive
it's expecting?
>> Victor, it's going to depend
on how many reenforcements that
Russians can get into the town
and whether they decide to go on
a full offensive.
If they did, they would bypass
that and not just look to stay
there and hold it.
What I see happening right now
from a military perspective is a
covering force battle.
That happens right before the
primary larger offensive scale
operations.
Reports I've seen show them
fighting along a front of about
500, 600 kilometers, very wide
there in the east.
Again, it's not giving the
Russians enough time to
reenforce with certain soldiers
as they planned on doing.
Ukraine is doing a very
incredible job using artillery
to fight back, as you saw,
attacking some of the Russian
soldiers in the open.
>> The casualty rate, as you
know, on both sides is extremely
high.
We don't know specific numbers.
They've been pretty opaque from
Ukraine and perhaps that's
understandable.
But how should they approach in
the early days of the offensive?
>> We have to be very concerned
that the equipment can't get
there on time.
We don't see tanks showing up
there.
There are certain videos you see
on the internet.
But they're howitzers and the
like.
Also, the ammunition, that in
and of itself is a tremendous
problem.
As the secretary-general said,
if nato countries don't start
mobilizing more artillery
rounds, it looks like Ukraine
runs out of ammunition in the
next few months given the amount
of artillery the Russians are
firing at them.
>> We heard from
secretary-general Stoltenberg
that, for example, the
large-caliber ammunition
increase Friday a 12 to 28-month
order placed to delivery time.
Something ordered today would be
delivered almost two and a half
years out.
Will there come a point at which
the allies will say no, we
simply cannot give you more
because we don't have it to
give?
>> I think that's going to
depend on how well the Ukraine
military does over the next 90
days.
If the Ukraine military can
actually threaten Russian
troops, maybe more in the south,
maybe threaten crimea.
If they can do that and show
they're making advances and at
least get to a hard stalemate on
the ground, then maybe they
negotiate.
The position they have is still
not what they want because
they've still given up some land
to Russia.
I think it's going to determine
how well they fight.
If they get Russia to the
negotiating table, it's going to
be a potentially long haul,
though.
We'll have to industrialize some
of our industries in order to
make sure we can meet that
requirement.
It's definitely excessive.
>> There's no indication that
Vladimir Putin is serious about
getting back to the negotiating
table any time soon.
We know Ukrainians continue to
ask for longer-range weapons.
Thus far the United States says
no.
There's a "Washington post"
report that says that Ukrainian
officials have only launched
these long-range, more advanced
weapons, the himarches in
particular with coordination
from the United States.
Do you think hearing that is a
sign from Ukrainians that
perhaps they can be trusted with
these longer-range weapon and
won't be directed into the
Russian Federation itself?
>> The himars are giving the
Ukraine military an advantage in
what was in the past mass fire
weapon, destroying wide swaths
of land in areas.
Now they can be much more
precise.
But the longer-range artillery
fire and missiles and rockets is
what Ukraine wants.
I think there's a real risk for
the United States government to
do that as those become truly
offensive weapons.
They could be launched into the
sea.
They could be launched over the
border into Russia.
I think that's where the slope
becomes slippery where, if
Ukraine wants to decide they
want to do that for their own
survivability, once we give
those weapons to them, we can't
get it back.
I don't know that it's a matter
of trust, but the type of
warfare for those weapons,
they're purely offensive.
>> You said we would have to.
I wonder if we means the west,
the allies of Ukraine, would
have to industrialize some of
our industry to provide
ammunition to Ukraine.
Are you talking about invoking
defense production to pass that
ammunition on to a third nation?
Is that what you're saying, or
am I getting that wrong?
>> I'm talking about actually
manufacturing.
Talking to people in that
industry, 155 artillery rounds
consists of dynamite shells that
are easy to manufacture.
The fuses are mechanical timed
fuses.
The different components for
those to be manufactured takes
time.
We'd have to secure the raw
materials to do that.
The United States manufactures
450,000 to 50,000 rounds for
itself on a monthly basis.
In order to help Ukraine, for
example, other nat tow countries
would have to supply about that
or more on a monthly basis.
We would then cut into our own
stocks, and that's just
something we're not going to do.
We would have to increase our
production of artillery rounds
in particular in order to meet
that objective.